Netflix's the Umbrella Academy is said
to be even better than the comic-book
series while the series stays pretty
true to the original they did make a few
major changes here's a list of the
biggest differences between the Netflix
show in the comics if you haven't
finished the series beware there are
spoilers ahead
Netflix is adaptation of The Dark Horse
comic book series stays pretty true to
the original series created by Gerard
Way and Gabriel day but in order to make
a 10 episode series the show's creators
had to make some significant changes to
the characters as well as the world
where they reside
for instance you won't find any
wrestling machines with alien squads or
a secret eiffel tower spaceship the
Netflix series is more grounded in
reality with a few fantastical pieces
such as Pogo the sophisticated
human-like chimp and the robot mother
but the major differences are with the
characters themselves just like the
comic series the story begins with the
spontaneous and simultaneous birth of 43
babies eccentric billionaire Reginald
snags up seven of those babies and
trains them to use their powers to save
the world in both the books and the show
he's a loveless father merely using his
children as tools and weapons his
parenting skills created severe
emotional trauma which was hard for the
kids to juggle as they tried to find a
way to put their past behind them
despite the setbacks they had to work
together to ensure the future of the
world the Netflix show has made some
notable changes to the characters
particularly when it comes to their
powers Allison's powers have been
altered slightly from the way she's
presented in the comics in the comic
Alison's words have the power to bend
reality to her will but in the show it
seems her powers are limited to
controlling the behavior and emotions of
others also Alison isn't a famous
actress in the comics
Klaus is flowers have been scaled back
in the show as well in the comics he has
telekinetic abilities but only if he's
barefoot in the show
Klaus is only able to communicate with
the dead in the comic series the
Umbrella Academy dallas klaus luthor and
diego jump back in time using a deceased
time travelers body so that they can
help v and allison but they missed their
target time destination and find them
selves in the middle of the Vietnam War
in the comic Klaus opens up a bar and
has a kid details are vague after that
in the show however Klaus steals hazel
and Cha Cha's suitcase and zaps himself
back in time to 1968 similar to the
comic he still finds himself in the
middle of the vietnam war but this time
he bites for about a year and falls in
love with an american soldier named dave
dave meets his demise in the war and
klaus suffers from PTSD which plays into
his struggles with addiction in the show
the comic doesn't really touch on PTSD
symptoms for Klaus so this is an
interesting deep dive into his character
in the show pen or number six plays a
troubled character who has the ability
to unleash a beast to defeat his enemies
in both the comics and the show Ben is a
mystery we know he can pummel his
opponents with monstrous tentacles and
that he seems tortured by this the show
dives into Ben's character more than the
comic books ever did but we still don't
know how Ben died thanks to Klaus and
his ability to communicate with the dead
we're able to see Ben on a regular basis
but as of right now he seems to be more
like Klaus his conscience until the
season finale we won't give too much
away but then is able to use his powers
in the physical world thanks to Klaus
his powers in the comic Luther's father
put his human head on the body of a
Martian gorilla but in the show Pogo
injects Luther with a serum to save his
life when Luther wakes up he has the
huge muscular hairy torso of a gorilla
Luthor's character in the show is one of
a strong Golden Boy with softness and
vulnerability beneath the surface this
makes it all the more devastating when
it becomes clear that Hargreaves sent
him to the moon for no real reason
in the comics Luther has an actual moon
mission Diego is portrayed as a rogue
Kira with ninja abilities and impressive
knife throwing skills in the comics
Diego has a relationship with inspector
Lupo a detective whose partner is a
talking chimp
Lupo gives Diego information on his
cases and begrudging Lee assist him in
his vigilante missions but in the show
Lupo is replaced by Eudora patch who is
Diego's ex this is a significant shift
from the comics in which Diego was
secretly in love with
vanya in the comics Vanya gets faded by
the conductor to join the orchestra and
attempts to destroy the world with their
apocalypse suite Vanya becomes the white
violin and she blows a chunk off the
moon in the show Vanya x' transformation
happens at a much slower pace and
leonard peabody takes the conductor's
place as the master manipulator who
baits fun yet but just like the
conductor Leonard meets his demise as
soon as Vanya gets control of her powers
number five is a time-traveling man
stuck in a child's body monitor all of
time and space to make sure that
whatever is supposed to happen happens
five secretly worked for an organization
called the Temps eternalists but netflix
riders changed the organization's name
to the Commission for obvious reasons in
the show it's implied too that five
assassinated JFK but in the Dallas comic
miniseries he went rogue and tried to
save the president instead then there's
hazel and cha-cha the to sugar addicted
sociopaths who wear cartoon masks in the
comics their presence is much larger in
the show and a bit more grounded in
reality in the show hazel and cha-cha
played disgruntled blue-collar hitmen
who are fed up with budget cuts and
bureaucracy they don't seem to love
candy as much in the show and they spend
more time maskless than they do in the
comics one major difference is that
hazel escapes with Agnes in the show
while cha-cha gets burned up in the
apocalyptic flames in the comics both
are destroyed by Klaus as psychic powers
the show is like a mix between Wes
Anderson's Royal Tenenbaums in a series
of unfortunate events with a hint of
x-men both the comics in the show
portray a family of emotionally broken
superheroes who must come together to
stop the end of the world they have
internal as well as external battles to
contend with which makes for interesting
character arts and while it deviated a
bit from The Dark Horse Comics it stayed
true to the overall plot while adding a
modern twist so what do you think did
you like the comics or the show better
tell us in the comments below be sure to
subscribe and follow the things to be
the first to see our latest videos
thanks for watching and see you next
time
[Music]